si nous raisonnons euros pour toi c 4
c'est la troisième fois qu'ils te
rattraper ça me rembourser un cap et
prix si vous avez besoin d'argent je
connais quelqu'un qui cherchait nous qui
propose un jeu qui va écoles la chose la
plus importante chante une comptine
africaines chez les bobos ça marche à
tous les coups foley kolélas petit à
petit ghosn est collé
bienvenue au square décorée si ça se
mélange pas trop on dirait et nous nous
c'est comme le foot chacun s'emploie
patronne l'art parfois elle revient plus
tôt et nous retire même des heures ok
mais bon on va en gestion c'est à quel
sujet une attaque digne assistant social
et juridique
appelé remettre à athènes qui nous toi
c'est pas mal ça des flics pour qu'on
arrête tu espérons c'est notre norme je
voudrais voir m sarr m sarr ce mois cela
du fait accompli merci attendez pas à
attendre sur un avocat sans papiers
l'ensemble à sa convenance en série
dans l'adversité toi le regarder comme
ça droit dans les yeux
la situation et croyez moi je peux tout
faire pour vous aider à
savoir promener résistants navy
je ne sais pas
dégâts